I also want people to buy tickets to
crazy rotations as well what if they can
only buy what tickets or do they buy all
gates for us first how is crazy rich
Asians I'm not in it I don't see it but
because it's gonna make you mad
well I was just because you'll see my
part you'll be like yeah yeah yeah she
doing I would love to see dog days but
the reason why kids and recreations and
she's my girl changed my mind about it
in my head like [ __ ] cans and Jimmy Oh
Yang's involved our podcast Jimmy your
yang awkward they've all done it and I
love these kids they're beautiful kids
nary talented right yeah and but when I
tried to read for it they were like nah
right Chinese that's true there's
everybody the movie Chinese either Ken
Jong Ken is actually the only non
Chinese Nico Santos Filipino oh he is
yes so in your face a can of worms but
then um colada goes it's the first Asian
comedy all cast Asian comedy that's
American of its kind
it's a studio movie and it's got to do
well in the box office and in an intern
it'll help everyone yeah uh uh you know
there's a great expression that I like
which is a rising tide lifts all ships
great expression don't reason to cry Dog
Days when the tide comes in all the
ships all the ships work that [ __ ] a
rising tide yeah even if the ships have
some of your absolute enemies on them
comedy and a wry right the end of that
expression is yeah some of those ships
hopefully will then tip over and some of
these [ __ ] will drown and you
will get all the parts a rising tide
lifts all ships I'm gonna that's a great
honor for writer Dennis I think I
memorize it's a super famous expression
I've never heard of it you've never
heard of a heart I don't never I don't
either somebody said to me one time
that's great
it's good yeah it's like a something
that's good for us it's good for all of
us is I was the only one in shock of
that
you've heard it before you really heard
that have you heard of team sports
they say that no how about you torch his
man I thought that about it let us
recite it when we're talking a rising
tide lifts all ships mmm feels good and
then some of them tip over and your
enemies dock comedy yes yeah that's
right that's the second part of them
yeah and some of your enemies just fall
off the [ __ ] back around like baby
okay
and then you gurgling for oxygen they
can't get it no that's right and then
you get your then your technically
available right and then the sea
creatures eat their dead vibe no I
worried about you something I mean I
love you the core and then sometimes
every once in a while I worried nibble
nibble right the flesh anyway
[Music]